[Music]
so
[Music]
last winter amazon started production on
the third season of the boys now it is
finally known when a season start can be
expected to the joy of many fans the
waiting time is kept short because the
season will be available on amazon prime
video as early as june 3rd 2022
fittingly the first teaser was released
which is expectedly short but definitely
makes you eager for more you can see
anthony stars homelander and aaron
moriarty starlight obviously in the
headquarters of the 7 where especially
homelander is in the flurry of camera
flashes of the reporters the longer the
scene goes on the more confusing serious
he looks and it is quite likely that the
focus on the upcoming season could
clearly be on the homelander in addition
to him and starlight the other main
characters will also be returning to the
screen including carl urban as butcher
jack quaid as huey and dominic meg
eligot as queen meth together they will
once again bring plenty of action satire
and black humor to the series while they
will also be joined by some newcomers
for instance we will get to see
supernatural story jansen eccles as
soldier boy and the walking dead star
actress laurie holden as crimson
countess they are members of another
super team called payback children eric
kripke is in charge of production while
the infamous duo of seth rogen and evan
goldberg will also keep an eye on the
same thing the first three episodes of
the third season of the boys will be
released on june 3rd after which a new
episode will be released every week
[Music]
[Music]
you